I want to talk about the world that
we're living in right now because like I
said at the beginning there's a lot of
strange things happening we saw
lockdowns medical coercions mandates
inflation's at a 40-year high nobody
seems to know what a woman is these days
um so I want to get your take on what
you think the hell is going on right now
what I love about this week nobody knows
what a woman is so here's here's how how
awesome this is you know why I like to
interview Communists I think I am we've
interviewed more Communists on
valuetainment than any other channel on
YouTube and the reason for it is the
following
the key with a communist or a socialist
is to let them talk
the more a socialist talks the more
communist talks eventually you know what
happens there's flaws in their argument
it doesn't work so so let's just say
this whole thing with women right
the question is asked so what's a woman
oh why are you asking me a question like
that I'm not a biologist to answer that
question you don't need to be a
biologist know what a woman is right
yeah but I'm just not in that space so
just ask me a different question but
what is a woman if you think you're a
woman you're a woman oh really yeah okay
cool no problem four weeks later that
same person is arguing for women's
rights you can't do that now so so but
what happens all of a sudden is they get
stuck and they're like oh my God now
what do I say what just happened is your
BS got exposed that's a beautiful thing
when you and I don't have an argument
okay and you try to keep selling your
point the more you talk if you truly
have an argument then it's I want to be
like you know what she's got a good
point but if it's BS the more you talk
then there's going to be leaks and
forget about me seeing the leaks in your
argument you're gonna see the leaks in
your argument now you're gonna like oh
let me change the subject and deflect or
go a different place we've all done this
I've done it as a kid you do it as an
adult you do it as a you're going to go
through this naturally the biggest thing
about today is bad ideas don't work bad
policy have consequences ludicrous ideas
eventually get exposed and people are
not naive or dumb for the small
percentage that wants to protect their
egos and follow through on their parents
politics whatever their parents politics
were some people will never be
Republicans because their dad cheated on
their mom and you will never ever get
them to be a republican because to
become a republican means you're saying
your dad was okay for what he did some
kids will never become Democrats or
republican because of upbringing some
people want to become because it was a
rich person in the family that left you
and you didn't spend a lot of time with
them so to everybody you see in your
life you see it as that I was 14 years
old the first time politics was
something that I was having to think
about because our Miss Luz our teacher
was talking about it so I come home and
I said Mom are we Democrats or are we
Republicans and she says uh yeah we're
Democrats I said why are we Democrats
and she says we're Democrats because
Democrats are for the poor and
Republicans are for the rich
I said you know when I grow up one day I
want to be a Republican and I have no
clue what a republican is all I meant to
say is as a kid is I want to be rich one
day I'm a registered independent today
center right politically full capitalist
when it comes on to economy but I think
they're losing because their arguments
make zero sense long term
but why are we at this point where these
policies and arguments although they
make zero sense are actually being
implemented and rolled out um Across
America but also across the world
because Americanization is very powerful
and very real the moment you're within a
clerk
most people feel the obligation to agree
with anybody on your Clique says right
and it's very hard to disagree with
people in your own Clique so parents
your dad believes in something it's hard
to say I don't know if I believe mom
says I don't know if I believe that
right okay all right so if you're you're
a you've always voted Democrat okay and
the Democrats say well here's a trans
this
you look around you're like
oh okay I got 19 other Democrats I
respect are saying this yeah so here's
what and you're like but I don't believe
that
okay that was kind of weird I don't but
okay it's not a big deal let's let this
one go it's not going to be a big deal
and then they say but but let me also
tell you this and here's why if you
don't take this you're not being
responsible and you're somebody that's
maybe a freedom of choice when it comes
down to you know abortion of pro-life or
pro-choice you're pro-choice and you're
like why am I forcing this person to
take what they don't want to take isn't
that pro-choice but everybody on my side
is saying
yeah okay yeah you gotta take it if you
don't you don't care about my health
because you're putting my life in
jeopardy you're irresponsible and then
you go home and you're like that doesn't
make any sense though right so some
unfortunately will blindly vote for
anything that their side says very few
people will question and those who
question eventually will get closer to
the truth and those who don't will be a
pawn that that party is going to use
until you eventually can think for
yourself
thank you